hey so yeah i'm here today to talk about
uh
python and h2o um so i'm gonna
talk about myself for like five seconds
and then about h2o for about 20 seconds
then i'm going to jump into a python
demo
so um who am i um i've been writing code
for uh you know like more than 40 years
um i built my first compiler when i was
15 so it's not the usual
usual story for 15 year old kids i've
been doing distributed computing for 30
years 20 years doing os device
drivers um i'm sort of the the
the guy who did the core guts of the hot
spot jet that made
you know java go fast and also showed
the world that basically
you could get code and now everyone does
it um and i've got
all kinds of hundreds of talks and
dozens of patents and it's all kind of
fun stuff
so i'm sort of a really hardcore serious
low-level deep hacker
i've watched the computer stack grow up
from you know nothing to what it is
today
and i understand it at all kinds of
layers um
so that's where i'm at and where i'm
coming from um
h2o is this uh project i've been working
on for the last three years
uh and it's an open source you can get
off github uh
platform for doing machine learning on
big data so distributed in memory
um and and very fast but also
the best quality algorithms we can get
um so i'll talk a little about how we
get there
but the the core notion here is you're
going to be able to run
um generalized linear modeling gradient
boosted method random force deep
learning pca teams there's lots of them
and more
we keep adding more um and then we have
a lot of connectors
um so well it's written in java so
obviously you can connect with from java
we have a very strong r uh connector
that we've
had working well for the last year and a
half maybe
we basically cloned that technology to
do a python
wrapper and i'll show you how that works
that's my demo come up here in my five
minutes
and spark and scala and there's a click
through browser guides that you can be
one of the uh what the last guy called a
suit and
click click click and get a good model
good predictions out
and um and clustered computing so that
means big data
so however much data will fit in however
big much remember you have in a cluster
um we can spin up a terabyte cluster in
seconds
on ec2 it's not very expensive and load
a terabyte of data into it and begin
modeling immediately
okay so um a quick company slide uh as
usual with startups the slide's already
old there are several faces missing
uh i think the the takeaway here at the
bottom
is the scientific advisory council um
stephen boyd rob chipterani and trevor
hastie
or sort of like the the modern uh three
musketeers of the mathematical and stats
community
these guys are writing inventing the
newest to the new
the best of the machine learning
algorithms out there um and
and they come and visit us and we go and
visit them on a regular basis so our
algorithms really are
uh you know the the newest to the new
and the best the best
it's good stuff um so uh
uh this is my one you know community
related slide here
so we're building a practical machine
learning tool um and what does practical
mean it means
uh different things to different people
so on the left here you know fast
interactive
means in memory so we're memory speed
we're not disk speed
so so order of magnitude is uh
seconds to to low minutes to build
models on uh you know hundreds of
gigabytes to terabyte
right so big data the reason for the big
data is you don't have to go
through the pain of so much sampling um
you can use everything you got
if your cluster is big enough and we're
actually very uh
parsimonious on memory so really if you
have a csv
on disk that's a terabyte it'll load
into a terabyte and ram
uh just like that and that of course
drives the requirements that you have to
be distributed so this is distributed
computing now
so it's clustered stuff it's open source
you can see
and know how it works see what the
algorithm is doing see why it's there
if there's a flaw or some new feature
you want to add you can go look at the
code and see what's going on
we have a very nice api
for coding distributed computing at
scale so it's based on a mapreduce style
paradigm and i'll go
as far as you want into how that works
when we get there
i'm going to demo stuff first but it has
nothing to do with hadoop's mapreduce so
i say mapreduce don't think hadoop
i think like kind of like the python
version if you will it's a very
theoretically clean map and reduce
and it leads to a very simple coding
style so that you can focus on writing
the math
and the the data munching in the code
that you want to do
and not focus on the issues of how to
write a cluster how to define
uh you know open api message passing
whatever none of that [ __ ] happens you
just write
straightforward simple inline code in
java at this point
and it will run it distributed and scale
out so we auto parallelize in that sense
um it's very portable being java
and uh on the inside for the
implementation and on the outside layer
there's a rest json api and anything
that can do rest and json can talk to
the system
and that's how we're gonna drive it from
python and then because it's a cluster
you have to have a cluster somewhere
i'm gonna run a cluster of one on my
laptop you can run it in your private
data center
you can run it in ec2 or in any cloud
computing um you know
four machines in this room if multicast
is enabled could cluster up just in
seconds
so it's really fast to launch a cluster
and it's just one jar file java dash jar
run a cluster you're good shoot that
here as we go
okay so a little tiny bit of high level
architecture
and then we're going to dive into demo
here so um there's a core thing
and the colors are all messed up the
core thing and kind of the lower middle
is um the right block is distributed in
memory key value store
we have a very high speed high quality
key value store
um we don't market and sell it because
that market's flooded
but it makes for easy coding we columnar
compressed data the compression
strategies typically get
2 to 4x better than gzip on desk so when
i talk about being we're low memory
consumers we are
we're typically better than your gzip
file by a fair amount better
and that in turn means that we can
stream data through the memory buses and
up into the cpu registers
at two to four x better than you can
stream
the uncompressed data so it's actually
faster to have it compressed and we will
decompress it only in the machine
registers and throw the compression away
it's all run off the java heap so we run
with gc but we use a very
um the default collector with max heap
settings will give you
excellent performance because the way we
structure the data
from that core we build these algorithms
so i'm listing here
a handful we have quite a few more and
sort of generic data munching we're
basically putting together a large
vector
calculator distributed vector calculator
scale and we write algorithms using that
over that layer we have a bunch of
interfaces including the rest and json
on one side leading out to uh where it
says r and the execution does python as
well
um or spark and scala where scala is in
process in the jvm so it doesn't need to
go through the rest layer but it has the
same
interface ultimately and then we can
emit a model out
on the right hand side it's basically
pretty printed model as java code but we
could pre-print it in any language you
want it's not hard to write a pretty
printer
and then that model is standalone can be
taken into a some production setting
which doesn't have to have h2o anywhere
in sight
can be written in python or wherever
your c
c plus plus 4 train wherever you want to
take that model it's standalone by
itself
and they can make predictions um
generally
in you know high nanos low microseconds
depending on the complexity of your
model
okay okay so demo i'm gonna as a demo
i'm gonna run ipython notebook
i'm gonna grab uh 10 million rows of
data of
city bike from city bike of new york
city so this is uh
bicycles that are all over the city and
bike stations and
you put a credit card you grab a bike
out of a locked rack
and you have a bike until you return it
to some rack and then you're charged for
the duration you held the bike
so i have 10 million trips and i'm going
to
run a little pseudo data science game
here i'm going to try and figure out
the number of bike trips that leave any
given station on any given day
because at the end of the day the
bicycles get redistributed around the
stations
and at the start of the next day they
have to be reload balanced
so that busy stations that are by major
metro centers need more bikes
but you know if somebody rode their bike
off in the boonies and then took a taxi
back and left the bike somewhere else
it's not where it needs to be at the
start of the new day so a manager
of city bike wants to rebalance bikes at
night run around with a truck and move
bikes from here to there
how many bikes should he move from where
to where and that's the question i'm
gonna i'm gonna look at answering
okay in the demo okay so
uh i'm going to fire up um
a python notebook here and see that okay
bam i5
notebook i'm going to fire up a cluster
of one so here's java
i'm going to xmx8 gig you can't hardly
see it but there's one jar file
and that gives me a cluster of one and
in about that much time if i'd had
a second one i'd get a cluster of two or
three but i'm just doing this on my
laptop
to make life easier for demos so go
through demo
grab the city bike large demo oh great
i'm updating things okay so here's
i thought python notebook um
let me clear all prior things and
and go so import the h2o h2o and net
this step says go find a cluster and if
i get an ip and a port it would go find
h2o cluster wherever i have it
i gave the default so it went to the
default port that h2o comes up in the
default
and basically it says i have access to
an eight gigabyte uh
h2o cluster um with four cores
see here
so there's a setup to go find my data
and here's a bunch of csv files
and i'm just going to start it here in a
second i'm going to let the demo take
off and run
but this is pulling data from disk into
the java heap and if i switch over to
the java window
i can see i've got a parallel parse of
the pin files going
uh and i'm pulling in a couple gigabytes
of data here
and we'll get my give my give my uh
there it's done
there's some summary gets printed out
okay so back in my python notebook
i just loaded in 10 million rows and 15
columns of data it was a couple
gigabytes on disk
and there's a list of the files that
went through so at this point i'm going
to let this python notebook take off
and then i'm going to start talking
stuff here run all below
make sure i get that right here
okay so uh now i'm we're looking at
python code
that's uh doing data munching and so the
first thing is i've pulled out
a thing i've called data that is the
name of the data frame
i have in python so what's a data frame
it's same as an r data frame it is a
two-dimensional table
with named columns going across and 10
million rows going down
and it's distributed throughout a
cluster in this case it is a cluster of
one but if i had a cluster of ten
machines it would have roughly a million
rows in each machine
or maybe i would have uh a billion rows
or
a hundred billion rows um and that would
be distributed around my cluster
and then the the columns going across
are essentially a python dictionary
i can name them i can also have an order
so you can give them by index
and you can mess with them so i pulled
out start time
come up with a constant for seconds per
day and i do a division of the
start time for the bike trip by seconds
per day i'm telling you what day did
that bike trip start on so just coming
up the day the bike trip started
so i have a map on uh 10 million rows
and that
ran through here and i have an output
which wraps because the font is small
and the last column here days has showed
up
uh and you can't see it but somewhere in
here is like 1587
is the day since the epoch and there's a
16 314 is the max day and those
between those two is the range of a year
and a half of days since the unix epic
okay so basically i'm trying to show
some little bits of data munching
so here's group by so i'm going to group
by the
day since the epic and the start station
name well how many stations what's this
i have 340 stations here
so i'm going to come up with 340
stations by about 400 days
about 140 000 rows after the group buy
what i'm really doing is i'm counting
bicycle trips
that are starting at every station and
every day so i'm going to end up with
the number of bikes that left a station
on a given day
and uh that's the h2o group buy here
being called out from python
and then a little show and description
here
is a summary of that this is about 140
000 rows
the days are going from you know 15
000 to 16 000. um the bike strips are
from
one here to a max of 691 an average of
74.
standard deviation of 64. it says that
i've got about
i've got a lot of variation some
day some station one bike some day some
station almost 700 bikes
and in between there's a very wide
variation so i'm trying to make a
prediction
how many bikes are leaving a station on
any given day but i have a lot of
variation so i'm going to make a
prediction
to try and and you know figure out what
the right number should be
but starting with a very large variance
so one of the other things i'm going to
throw in here real quick
is oh here's a sample the first 10 rows
that the bikes per day dot show was
here's 10 rows
i could ask for all 10 million but but
we'll just
you know here's the station and here's
the number of bikes that left that
station on that day
the other thing here is um i printed out
the compression
the the output at this point says that i
have about a megabyte
after compression to hold the data so it
is really shrunk it down a lot here
so this is i've took in a data set
that's a static thing
and i'm going to make a build a model on
it and then use it to make predictions
so given that model the the
you know the manager at citibike could
plug in the day
and the weather coming up here i'll mess
with weather as well and come up with a
set of predictions on how many bikes he
should have
so that that's how that's supposed
that's the that's the demo model i'm
working toward
how it would actually work for this guy
i don't know but i'm going to come up
with a set of predictors that should be
readily available
that he could use to turn around and
make his predictions from
okay i'm throwing out quantiles real
quick so the one percent quantile was
two
and the 99 percent quantile was almost
300 and whatever it just shows like
fast but i've talked too long and so my
demos rolled forward here
here is um i just took the same i'm
going to feature engineer
months into this thing with the thought
that
some number of people are going to take
a bicycle ride
in july because it's pleasant weather
and if you're riding in january
you're riding in snow and sleet and crap
and so probably you're only riding a
bike because
it's your daily job that you must ride
that bike for whatever reasons how you
get around
so january and july are probably
interesting indicators of who's writing
and why
same thing for day of the week if i'm
writing on a weekend it's probably
a joy ride if i'm writing on a monday
morning it's probably because i'm going
to work
so i threw in some predictors which i
just did by doing the basic math
on the the start day to convert that
into a month
and a day a week so standard sort of
time-lunging things and i added a couple
new columns
by just basically assigning bikes per
day i signed a new call a month but i'd
never seen before which i just stick by
seconds
convert it to month but done in parallel
it scaled across the cluster
and i come up with a new data set has
some more stuff then i have this big ass
function here
which i'm going to talk about briefly
and then jump to the bottom and show the
good stuff
so this is a classic test train split
hold out
operation i pick a random uniforms from
the r
uh from the our uh uh idiom a random
uniform number from zero to one
uh and then for every row in the data
set i select
if you're in uh uh in the training test
or hold out based
on whether the random number was 0.6
between 0.6 and 0.9 or above
so what really i'm showing here is this
expression auto expanded under the hood
to do
a parallel distributed array math of a
random number
that was already sorted throughout the
cluster and 0.6 a constant come with a
column of booleans
and then the boolean was used as a
selector to pick up to pick a a train
element
same here this was a random column of
booleans a random column of williams
there's an ad
that went across the cluster in parallel
and then a selection made for
test and holdout and so on so i'm doing
data munching
where i'm auto expanding uh uh
operations i'm doing across a big array
in
including
you know in parallel around my cluster
and then i'm running my high-end
algorithm so here's a gradient boosted
method
random forest in glm i've handed in
test and train i'm handing in my
response column which is the bikes
for gbm i've said you know 500 trees and
a max depth and a learn rate
and uh you know for tlm there's some
family it's poisson's accounting
problems i'm using a poisson
distribution instead of a
gaussian or a logistic or something um
you know lambda set to whatever and away
it goes
so then i'm going to print things and
these models have already been built
while i've been yacking
because i'm talking too slow now but
what i can see out of here is
it's a regression model so it's a count
of bike trips
so i have an r squared i'm printing out
and it's seeing that the
gradient boosted method has come up and
says i've got a 96 percent on my train
but if you go to the test set you see
it's like 92 there's a little bit
overfitting going on
but 92 percent of my variance has been
explained here by this model
just straight up so without any further
work um
random force is not quite as good um i
could make the random forest run longer
and get a little better answer but it's
going to top out at a little lower value
typically
and then the generalized linear modeling
um
it doing doing reasonably well at 77
percent
um if i don't do poisson if i do a
gaussian distribution it sucks pretty
bad
but poisson it does a better job
okay so let me go see if i can make this
make make this go better here so i'm
going to add some weather
so i did a month and i thought well
maybe i can grab some weather data
and say was it raining that day so if
the prediction is it's going to rain
today
is that going to impact your riding a
bike right you want to get your you know
how wet do you want to get right
so i went ahead and grabbed hourly
weather data from new york city for the
two years in question
and i printed it out here and of course
after the
i see aha i see what's going on okay
hang on
the problem is that my mouse slides down
the podium
and drags to the bottom where the
windows all pop up it's all very
exciting
okay so there's way a ton of columns
if i scroll on down you can't see
because of the wrapping but
most of them are missing there's a huge
count of missing elements in here
i'm going to weigh down here okay i know
you can't tell what's going on
but all the numbers that say 17 000 and
such rolling y
those are all counts of missing rows out
of my seventeen thousand or so
hours per day on two years so a lot of
missing and then there's the compression
on the weather data okay
so a lot of the data is kind of junky so
i'm gonna throw most of it out i'm going
to subselect weather too from weather 1
by only picking some things that look
sensible
including all the time fields because i
need to use them for a join
let them grab like to do point humidity
the precipitation the temperature and
the weather code number one had some
stuff in it including like it's
node like are you riding in the snow or
not and then rename some of these long
columns are shorter and it can
almost fit it on one screen it wraps a
little bit here um
but you can see the dew point on the
right uh from
uh minus 26 to 24 the humidity level
from
0.12 to 1 the mean humidity is 60
percent
now i live in you know san jose 60
sounds like like a hot house yeah
okay fine uh it would certainly impact
my my desire to ride
um and then if i look at the missing
count on the the last row of data here
that's the weather code um uh
missing most of the days involved and
then the next one over is actually
the rain so so there's missing value for
rain
and it's here it's most of these are
missing so what i did with from next
here is i'm going to clean up some of
that stuff
um i'm going to cut the data set down to
just grab out the the weather at noon
because figure i don't actually care
about the weather at midnight or even
after you're done riding a bike for the
day and i didn't want to do an
approximation for the whole day so i
just grabbed noon weather
by simply filtering out that the local
hour was noon
and then i went ahead and took the year
month and day
columns and munched them together and
came up with milliseconds since the epic
by doing a standard time munching thing
and then converted those to
days since the epic same way i did
before and
i get an additional days column here and
some milliseconds
and then go ahead and drop all the old
time columns oh the rain where i say it
was missing
mostly when it's missing it actually
zero so
for the algorithms in question if the
data is missing they're going to do one
kind of thing
that it says they really don't know
where if we think that's actually zero
that says something very definitive it
didn't rain that day it's probably good
weather
so um so i went ahead and replaced the
missing values which in python would be
none with rain so again this is a
you know a big data math expression
where
rain equal equal none is simply an
equality check on missing value
and then that could mean with a boolean
vector of all the rows that we're
missing and then i assign a zero where
it was missing
fine um then i do a merge this is
effectively a join uh and then i'm going
to drop
extra columns and we skip the display oh
i didn't show the dropped columns all
right fine
so in in this summary here i'm looking
at 10 rows where
there's a day number there's a start
station name i have the station as an
enum
you can get printed out as well the
number of bikes that left that day the
month day of the week
the humidity fraction oh that first line
93 humidity that day
and half an inch of rain um and you know
going down you can see
different times and dates and missing
values and whatever and now i'm going to
run this
split fit predict again with weather
data
and so out of this i'm going to see that
the gbm remained at about the same level
the random force went from like 82 to 86
percent
and glm went up to 78 from 77 or 79
from 77 and just saying
i got good enough already so either new
yorkers are sort of immune to weather
or the month was a highly correlated to
the weather in new york
and i didn't need actually to add
whether they got like two percent across
the board
absolutely absolutely right
absolutely so so i'm doing a demo on
showing
us driving a clustered computing
solution and i'm not actually trying to
solve the data science problem
right so uh you could surely do a better
job here i'm i'm just
okay how's it how does it feel how does
it work
so so that's the the demo see
we've got lots of time left um i'm going
to talk a little bit more about h2o and
i'm going to break for q and a here for
a second
how about this okay so um sort of the
the the sort of takeaway here
is that we have a platform from doing um
big most any java code you want on big
2d tables so here on a python conference
i'm talking about java
really anything i can do in
python i can do in java and furthermore
most things i can pass over the wire
through the rest api
and so you get the same behavior in
python or in java
but the java side will take it to the
next larger scale
so and actually in the python code i was
writing
that stuff i was doing would work well
if it was all local
and the infrastructure we've got we'll
actually do it that way so it'll run
locally but you're limited by the amount
of memory you can put on a python
instance and the size of the data you
can hold in the python instance
when you load the data onto h2o instead
the infrastructure will move your calls
to a rest
api call instead of running it locally
in python and then it'll
do the big data um
internally uh the you know what we're
end up writing here
is a single threaded plain old java code
on plain old java objects
and we'll make it distributed in
parallel by default so i won't say i've
got an auto paralyzer going
but we've gone a long way for writing
code that's parallel distributed just
in a natural coding style um a 16-0 ec2
cluster we can run a billion row
logistic regression in four seconds
so not a small one not just billion rows
and 700 indicators
so a pretty big one um first parallel
distributing
instances of graded boosted method uh
deep learning
and then the other algorithms are all
sort of naturally done parallel in the
same way
where it says r integration you might as
well say python
same thing here and i ran it just like
you ran it you saw me run it there java
dash jar
there's no real gc tunings a common
bugaboo of java programs
we handle the heap well already
so that's the end of the python display
but i'll take questions on this for a
bit here and then we can
we can try something else here including
running this
step by step and watch it go yeah
no i'm saying i'm sorry so the
he asked he didn't understand the
comment about the restful api
scaling or not um and what i was trying
to say was
the we have a python wrapper that has a
data frame it's not
as well refined as like pandas but it's
pretty far along
that data frame will work on data that's
local in the python instance
or uh work with data that's in the
cluster
and if it's local it just runs a local
piece of python code to do the math
and if it's remote it builds an
expression builds a url
passes it over to the cluster does some
math and gets back a handle saying okay
the results you're looking for in the
cluster under this handle and then the
next step you do
uses that handle to go drive the next
job in the cluster
so the same workflow is going in python
or in a cluster where in python it's
limited by
what fits on your laptop and in the
cluster it's the size of your cluster
so it's the same workflow but it can be
you know 100 times bigger thousand times
bigger in the cluster
yeah i'm sorry
uh the answer of course is yes
let's see here uh let me go to the here
so here's this code
so um the
the expressions um that are just like
generic
uh do an array size bulk expanded
expression those are all evaluated
laser late so that just builds an
expression tree up
when i go to anything that does the
input or output or runs one of my big
arrows
that's done eagerly and at that point
all the lazy expressions get evaluated
so there is a point at which they get
evaluated so you do
printing displays or shows that has to
evaluate it
running the big algos evaluates it other
things will just accumulate
oh decide kit learn um we're
so um there's sort of a limited number
of algorithms inside kit learn
oh no scikit-learn i'm picking the wrong
guy um
i would i haven't done speed tests with
scikit-learn
i know that when i've looked at smaller
sets
um we're very comparable to generally
faster on all the
on all the machine learning tools that
are out there
and when the sets get very large we're
10 to 100 times faster
it becomes much much faster as things
get bigger
we would have to we could go do that
here
at any point in time and take a look
there is generally a scaling issue
for very small data sets we're not going
to be as fast as sort of
uh uh algorithms that are just doing an
algorithmic
solution to solve that one thing um but
i find that as the data sets go up to
like as soon as you hit a megabyte or a
couple megabytes
uh we're generally asked faster or
faster than anything out there and i'd
be happy to run that test uh here today
and look
take a look have you guys played with
scikit
yeah okay well tell me tell people
okay fine we should we should play the
game and find out because that's a good
one to know the answer to it especially
i'm going to do
more python conferences yeah
right
so um yeah okay so so
can i talk about the kinds of models so
um
we're we're a tool
shop we build tools so the tool is
for instance random forest or gradient
boosted method
so those tools don't they they're like a
like a saw it's what you build with it
is
is what you do right so it's not like
it's a population model or
not it's just what does the tool do
um so uh
we have customers from a very broad
swath
of uh we don't there's no one vertical
that people have picked us up on we have
people in healthcare
we have telcos we have a lot of ad tech
and marketing we have health insurance
we have a lot of finance we like credit
card fraud
some of these people are doing uh
supervised learning
um you know the credit card fraud people
they got 40 years of credit cards
uh you know transactions they know are
fraudulent or not um some of these
people are doing unsupervised learning
and they're looking for you know heart
palpitations and murmurs or
cancer on a x-ray blob or whatever it's
going to be
so it kind of varies all over the map
we really we hand the tool to the end
user and
and help them figure their bugs out they
generally don't share their data with us
um and they only sometimes share with us
the kind of thing they're trying to do
so i don't necessarily know what it is
they're doing with the tool per se
i've seen like cisco does a huge amount
of um
inventory control and part management
stuff
because they have a huge they're very
large manufacturer and they have a huge
count of different
things and they buy from all over the
world and they have a huge inventory
management flow problem
um so these the you know i've talked a
guy who who's
now building a thousand uh high quality
models where before he's building 60 000
disjoint models because of the size
issues he couldn't do
so now he's building one thousand times
fewer
uh models um 100 times fewer models
that are doing something to do with the
demand prediction
now is that a population model i i don't
know
okay yeah
ml lib sparking so um we sort of
think of spark as uh an enabler for us
so we are um we will totally co-locate
and co-work with spark
we don't do for instance sql which spark
does do
um generally we can go into a place that
has
a well-running spark cluster and plug in
to their spark cluster directly and then
give them machine learning
as far as you know the obvious piece
that goes with that is what about ml lib
we don't have as many different
algorithms as ml lib does
but ours typically run a hundred times
faster
10 to 100 times faster and generally
with much higher quality results
so the prediction quality is up and also
um
we have on staff people whose full-time
job it is to prove the validation the
correctness of the mathematical model is
getting built
so so one of the issues you have with
with building one of these tools like
gradient loosen methods very complicated
neural nets it's very complicated thing
so you get a bunch of java programmers
who are hacking systems people are doing
distributed coding everywhere
they have stack traces so you hit them
with standard qa
standard qa will find your java stack
traces and that will
you diagnose and fix all those bugs so
things that cause a stack trace become
less and less common and eventually
stable but it's doing math and so the
output of a mathematical algorithm is
a number it's your prediction is it the
right number
well the java hacker doesn't know so you
have to have a mathematician
who can do a white box deep dive into
what the algorithm is doing
in order to know that it's doing the
right thing to come up with a test that
says here's this funny data set that i
happen to know has a certain kind of
structure internally and if your
algorithm is correct you're going to get
this answer out
but if you're doing a bernoulli
distribution versus a gaussian
distribution or a logistic distribution
you're going to get a different answer
out and i can prove that
by throwing this data set at end to end
right so this requires somebody that
basically got phd in math so we have a
couple phds in math whose job it is to
do this kind of stuff full-time on staff
so these algorithms are also extremely
well tested
so it's um i'd like to say it's higher
quality
it's uh much faster and then um they're
also
uh all the bells and whistles for the
algorithms we do with their
complete indian have all the things you
might want to have out of these
algorithms
so i'm not showing other stuff coming
out of the gradient boosted method
but you know if i do a logistic model
i'll get an aec curve out
i'll have max f1 values i'll have the
you know min per class error and all the
different kinds of things you can use to
judge the quality of a model i can
immediately turn around compare that
to another model i've built you know
logistic regression with glm or random
force or deep learning and
look at the quality of the models and
that kind of you know the next step i
got a model oh but i got another model
another another another how do they
stack up
you know i can do that kind of stuff all
in h2o here
the core hacking is more efficient so
so unlike some of the other startups
we're a bunch of hardcore systems
engineers
who know our way around computer and
performance
and we've been learning the math so
we've had to hire mathematicians
and talk to you know rob trip johnny and
trevor hastie
in order to understand the math um and
you know they keep us honest in that
sense
but we can make machines hum so we have
better code and you can go look at the
github repo and see it and i can step
you through if you're interested in
what's going on
but for instance uh under certain
circumstances i can outrun blas
in java doing dumb ass math with like
what bloss is supposed to be the best in
the planet for
and and i can do it single threaded
single core but then i can do it
parallel distributed as well
and it's because i'm doing stupid
shortcuts that you just can't do in
fortran
because i can hack at a low level in
java
so um so separate out mini batching from
storm
so we we make a model we can we can
pretty print it as java
so now you have a java plain old java
object that'll do predictions
that'll plug into a storm bolt and we we
have a demo you go to our website
you can download and click through the
demo we plug it into a storm bolt
i'm sorry
it's a java model but it's closure if
you're doing closure it's
all gonna plug right in
yeah okay so um
right okay so so how much what's the
time here
another five okay um
we'll play for five minutes here and see
how far we get with it
uh i'll skip everything i can
and get down to okay so here is some
some data layout so
the the core infrastruc that the core
notion is we're coding to a distributed
array so an array has
uh an an accessor function at and a set
um there's a missing value notion and
then the length is longer than 2 billion
it's more than a java int
so it's a bigger red and it's going to
be very large it's compressed very
heavily
but i guarantee you you know memory
access memory bandwidth speeds if you
access it sequentially striding
it's distributed across my jvm's this
way
so some chunk of the array is on each
jvm
and actually i have a collection of them
because i have some sort of data frame
that has some real world connotation
the columns have labels and means
something to somebody
um however i guarantee you the alignment
such that any one observation
is on one jvm so if i have a math algo
that wants to talk about a particular
observation
all at once it was very common he
doesn't have to cross jvm boundaries
she's going from one array to another
think of it as a a
structure of arrays instead of an array
of structs
within any given vertical stripe of a
column i break things up into chunks
so somebody asked for mini batches a
chunk is typically a thousand to a
million elements
and that is my unit of compression and
it's my unit of parallel execution
the chunks are all aligned so that one
core one thread
will talk about a row and a set of rows
in those set of chunks
by itself so there's a thing single
threaded no synchronization no locking
kind of thing
from his point of view he's writing
single threaded code talking about a
thousand or a million uh
observations and of course he just
sweeps through them and that's my unit
of uh parallel execution so i said one
but it's actually
all the cores in your machine will grab
a different chunk and sweep through them
all
and so this is the classic uh data
parallel
uh map call where the map is going from
type a to type b
and then at the end of this the each
chunk will have to be reduced with its
neighbor
and that will get take two b's and make
one b of the type system right
um let me let me go back and step you
through that real quick here
we'll do a little little demo and do
this in five minutes okay so
um you know the coding paradigm that i
write to is i say make me a new java
object
an mr task we call it a mr task and then
hand it some data say do all and i get
one java instance
on one jvm somewhere these are all
peer-to-peer so i can pick anyone i want
to go at like pick one it's you make a
java instance okay great
he says oh i'm supposed to touch all
this data but it's everywhere so let me
go
hand a copy to each my two neighbors and
they hand a copy to their two neighbors
and so it's logarithmic in the depth of
the cluster
i pass this java object along and it has
all my initial state of whatever i'm
going to try to accomplish in this pass
through the data
so it might have things from the last
state accumulated already
it might have constants or flags or
whatever and it carries the code
the code went with it okay then on any
one node
it's a classic divide and conquer this
is dougly's fork join
right so one task says oh i have to
touch all the state on this one node
it's too much
i'll make another clone and say each of
us do half and again half and half and
half and so on
until i have one task for every chunk of
data and then i run the map call and at
that point
the code that's in that task executes on
that data single threaded one core one
one node
whatever all by itself and i get the
mapping from type a to type b
so the output is a task object has
whatever the result of that map function
is
it's in now hundreds of these tasks
thousands of them
scattered around the cluster so i have
to start doing reductions to bring them
back together
and then every time i have any two of
them immediately i'll do a reduction
so it's eagerly reducing uh two b's into
one b
and again step by step and a logarithmic
in reverse roll
up until i have one top level instance
per node and then i run the log true and
reverse screen back up the cluster
where everybody who has a result sends
it back up the cluster to the neighbor
and the reductions are done
uh on each of the nodes and turns it
rolls up the log tree until you get the
last reduction
into the top level instance and that was
a password of the data
that pass will take
uh you know a couple seconds for a
terabyte
on this eight node cluster uh
milliseconds for a gigabyte
kind of thing so it's it's it's memory
bandwidth speeds
typically it's extremely fast so i'll
i'll have to run passover paths for a
lot of these algorithms but i
they're cheap so this is not a hadoop
pass this is an
in-memory milliseconds per gigabyte kind
of pass
so i think this guy was first and then
i'll get to yeah
do we talk about i o cost or overhead
for maintaining structure
okay so so the overhead of splitting and
maintaining stuff is actually typically
infinitesimally small compared to the
size of the data it's just little tiny
bits of control saying
this many rows are here and how many
rows are there kind of thing the
i o overhead depends on what the job is
in this task how big the task is
relative to the size of the data
for some of our algorithms they're very
strongly scaling they need a very small
amount of i o
for every pass of the data and then uh
you know you can have more and more and
more
lesser and lesser machines and it'll
just keep
you know going faster and faster because
the the i o cost is so small
some of the algorithms io costs can be
very large and that is the dominant cost
you'd rather have a few fatter machines
and it varies by algorithm
so in the case of random forest the
histograms for a deep random force get
very large and you get bandwidth limited
on the network
and and you're shoveling over gigabytes
of histogram data and that is the
dominant cost
for a great boosted method the trees are
very small but you need lots and lots
and lots of them
and so it's actually latency bound to
the network not
uh bandwidth bound we generalize linear
modeling um
there's very little traffic over the
network at all it's very strongly
scaling
it almost doesn't matter uh how many
machines you have and how big the
network or how slow the network is it
just add more cores it runs faster
so like it varies by algorithm
okay fine okay so um
i'll be around afterwards uh at the
booth here um
h ai there's some other people you can
go see amy and spencer and ray's holding
around here somewhere
i think matt's around here somewhere too
um so we have a whole crew here we
answer questions and i guess it's time
for lunch
oh one more talk
thank you